Nice.
So we're rolling.
This Is the book. We're
Oh, wonderful. Thank you. Yeah,
just to take a look at it. I on Amazon.
Yeah. Some people, some people pronou it that way.
Did they go on Teaching
Discipleship And she's
Helping her mother
and then moved into a new place? Hello? Steve?
How
Brother?
Yeah. Yeah. Well, right.
Pro Germany would
be ei be.
I just turned it on. I'm ready. It's ready to go. Mm-hmm.
Thank you. Sherry, you not staying?
Huh? Oh, you got the girl cut. Thank you. Alright.
Thank you very much. You, did we follow that?
I mean, is there homework? And we have to,
and if you're taking this, I'm not taking the
class, although I'd love to.
Do we have extra values for that now? We saw?
Yeah. It was on a day or two.
No, we we did, but they sold out quick. So a good
Discernment or I wouldn't even even talk
about There he is.
He's back here. Should never doubted me.
You missed last week, didn't you?
Here? Oh, I may forgot to do that.
You got all your assignment done? Of course.
Yep. Good. Finished about 20 minutes
Ago. Alright.
Sunday. I,
when I was added to the group, it was just the teachers,
the teachers group, not just the
Teachers. It was
like the ones that had been teaching. Oh yeah.
It wasn't the regular. That was a
we praying, we wanted the men to be part of the prayer
because
gonna
Go ahead and get started. I think we're ready
To go. Yes,
sir.
Well, good evening everybody.
Thank you. Thanks.
I love the responses.
Um, we'll go ahead and get started
and we can let people trickle in who want to come here
after the buzzer, but if you have not gotten
handouts, they're up here.
So there's two and a memory verse.
Does everybody have the two handouts and the memory verse?
I don't have reverse One reverse. Okay.
Most important Thing to sign that role
And sign the roll.
All right, well welcome. We've made it to, oh,
I thought I had the week number up there.
Maybe I've got it on the handout. I think this is week six.
Yep. Okay. Of systematic theology if you made it this far.
Wow. Good for you.
Um, and we're gonna be, uh, tackling a tough one tonight.
So we're gonna be talking about the trinity
and this is one of those doctrines that, um,
I think will make your head spin a bit.
And if you were here two weeks ago
and I taught on the meat communicable attributes I told you
that would make your head spin.
I think they all kind of make your head spin a little bit.
But this one specifically will tonight come on in
Right there.
Alright. So I'm gonna, I'm gonna pray
for us in just a minute,
but I always want to have kind of a cold open
and why this doctrine is important.
Okay? Lemme just ask the question.
I wasn't going to, but I'm gonna,
why is this doctrine important?
Why is the trinity important?
Helps us understand the nature of God.
Yeah. It helps us understand who God is.
Each one has a role And each,
Each of the eternity has a
Role, whatever we're gonna call that
Yes.
Has a role. Right? So father, son will, right
Holly, he is was so prevalent nature world
that monotheism is expressed in that trinity.
And that's just an important fact. It's not
How it feels.
It's tomorrow feels expressing itself.
And we're gonna talk about that
because that of all the critics out there,
that's one of the things that trips up people the most.
They would say that we would be worshiping three guys.
And that three in one concept is just
really hard to sink in.
Right? Anything else?
Why the trinity, why this doctrine is important?
Well, I'm gonna show you two reasons here
and we're gonna start with something we might not always
talk about in church.
But I'm gonna read a passage from the to start.
I'm, I'm okay, I'm setting up.
I thought you forgot setting up for the prayer.
Let me just read this verse though.
Out of the Quran that says, oh people
of the book and that's us.
Okay? That's Christians commit no excesses in your
religion, nor say of Allah.
But, but the truth. Christ Jesus, the son of Mary,
was no more than a messenger of aah
say not Trinity desist.
It will be better for you.
For Allah is one God glory Beto him far exalted as he
above having a son.
And from Ali's, uh, footnotes
and his translation, he says, the doctrines of Trinity
equality with Allah and sonship are repudiated
as blasphemies.
Allah is independent of all needs
and has no need of a son to manage his affairs.
Okay, so point number one is
you may have heard that Christianity
and Islam worship the same God.
We don't believe that. And right here, we don't need
to go any farther than what's up here on strength one God,
the God of Islam goes out of his way
to say he does not have a son.
Mm-hmm. Christianity
and our God really went out of his way to say that He does.
Good point. Yeah. So we don't have to go any farther.
We don't have to go into the moral codes
and all this kind of stuff between the two religions to know
that they are very, very different.
And one of the clear separations is this idea
of the trinity.
Okay? Second point, as we remain on Islam,
you've heard of the Dome of the Rock.
Mm-hmm. Okay.
Over on the Temple Mount in Jerusalem, constructed by AB
and 6 92 ad.
Here's kind of the schematic of it.
And all over this, at the pointer here,
all over this, this is the only original part
of ab Malik's construction we still have today.
And that's this inner ambulatory in the center part
inside the dome of the rock.
And all over that in tile mosaics
are inscriptions in Arabic.
And right here on the eastern wall
and the inside of the wall, we see basically
that same verse, that same Quranic verse.
Okay? And if we go a step farther, all
of these yellow stars are inscriptions that would
denounce the trinity.
They all claim Allah.
One, he has no partners, he has no associates.
And Jesus was not his son.
And he was only a messenger, only a prophet.
So you wonder, they went through such great lengths
in this building to be a polemic
against the Trinity of all the things
that they could write about their God.
They chose to really spend a lot of energy on
Dean Nelson the Trinity.
So it's very, very important. Very, very important.
So with that, we're gonna pray. Okay?
Father, you are such a good guy.
Thank you for revealing
who you are in your scripture.
Thank you that you have given that to us.
Thank you that we have it in English in our
own native tongue.
It wasn't written that way, but we have it today.
So we know the word of God and we know clearly what it says.
And we know that you are a triune God.
And Father, that that topic is so important.
It's such a hot topic.
It's a hot button, really in the world today
that many people disagree with that.
And so, father, I pray
that you would just reveal your truth to us tonight.
I pray that my words would be truthful.
I pray that we would be edified.
I pray that we would walk out today
with just a better understanding, not just of an academic
doctrine, although we want that too,
but that we would walk away blessed
and really just knowing you better
and who you are just a little better when we leave
than when we walked in.
So Father, I pray that you'll be gracious to us
and help us to do that tonight.
We pray that you'll be glorified too. In Jesus name. Amen.
Alright, so our outline tonight,
because it's so important,
we wanna make sure we have a solid definition.
And we're gonna spend a lot of time on this.
This will be, it'll feel like walking through mud,
but sometimes we gotta walk through mud to get
to the place that we want to go.
Okay? So bear with this, it'll be a little technical.
Then we'll get to the essentials of the doctrine,
recognizing errors in the teaching on Trinity,
and then the work of the Trinity in our lives tonight,
because we wanna have some application, right?
And we're gonna end up with David
and he's gonna kind of bring us home with some questions,
uh, that he's put together.
So the definition,
and we're gonna start with, we can,
we can have a little analogy here that I, I kind
of liken this as a,
we're gonna tightrope over the Grand Canyon, Okay?
How would we go about tightrope and
or tightrope walking over the Grand Canyon?
Um, very carefully. Very carefully, Victor. Yeah.
But we want to have an idea of
where we're headed first, right?
It's almost like it's very common, right?
So you don't get seasick air sick, right?
You want to have a stable event that you can look at so
that when we're rocking back and forth, we don't get sick.
And I think tight roping, we want to, we want
to see the other side.
We don't want to get caught in the middle
and start looking down, right?
We want to see the other side.
So we're gonna start by looking at the other side.
Otherwise, I could never really enjoy myself.
I could never give,
is this a Samsung tv?
Because
That's not where we're going.
No, this is not where we're going.
Alright? I think it always takes twice
before it connects.
Here's where we're headed. We are headed towards
our definition, which we're gonna go out
of Wayne Broom's book.
It's very, very, it's very, very good definition.
It's very simple, okay?
And I think we need to start with the simple.
I know that we're headed towards the simple,
because we're not gonna get
into the simple here in a minute.
It says, God eternally exists as three persons,
father, son, and Holy Spirit.
And each person is fully God. And there is one God.
Simple, simple enough. We get that Maybe, maybe not.
If you want a little, little bit more meat on the
bone, we can stay modern.
And here's Phoebe Orfield's, uh,
definition from about a hundred years ago.
There is only one or one only in true God,
but in the unity of the Godhead, there are three co-eternal
and co-equal persons the same and substance,
but distinct in subsistence.
Okay? You see that's basically Broome
with a little bit more hump to it.
And we don't have to understand all these words perfectly.
We're gonna get to that. Okay?
Needless to say, when we're on this tightrope,
it's gonna be easy for it to start swaying back and forth.
And we want to make sure
that we're always looking straight ahead.
This is where we're going. Just remember Bruno's definition
that we're gonna go back and we're gonna actually build
through church history,
our understanding of the Trinity.
Okay? Before we start going into what does the Bible say?
'cause what does, what does the Bible say about the trinity?
Where is the verse that talks about the Trinity?
Genesis one, one. Who say it? Anybody have one? Genesis one.
One it The word trinity.
Oh, the word trinity. No word. Sorry. Okay.
I think I might know where you're
headed and we can get there.
And as Christians,
we've pretty much exhausted all the things we can get out
of the scripts are about the trinity,
but the word trinity itself, like David said, is nowhere.
So it's amazing that we have a definition
of the trinity without one being given
to us in the scriptures.
Okay? So think about that too.
Keep that in the back of your, your heads.
So we're gonna go back to the beginning.
And the very first church father
who mentions the word trinity, is this guy named Ian.
You may have heard of him.
Uh, he was, uh, head
of the church in a town called Carthage.
It's in modern day Tunisia, okay? In North Africa.
And here's a little bit about what he says.
He wrote in Latin, uh, people on the west side
of the church, early church spoke Latin from primarily.
So all are, are of one by unity that is of substance.
There's that key word substance, okay?
Latin words are very beliefs. Yeah.
And the unity into a Trinity Triose placing in
that order, the three persons, which is the Latin persona,
the Father, the Son, and the Holy Ghost.
So Ian really kind of nailed it here.
And this is only about, well, it's about 180 years
after the death of Christ.
Okay? But you can look at that one of two ways.
One, why did it take him so long?
And the other one, how I look at it is, it's remarkable
that, that early in the church,
they had a definition of trinity.
'cause it's not spelled out in scripture.
These people have a mastery of the scripture enough
to really understand who God is.
Okay? To me, I think that's, that's pretty fascinating.
Uh, but we see basically almost everything here in Groove's
definition, way back in the year two 13, okay?
The state of the Catholic church, uh, they,
they were all in a Catholic church back then.
That's kind of what they call the church.
It was the church Catholic.
We today have a different understanding of
what the word Catholic means.
It just means general, it's the general
church back in those days.
So they would all say they're part of the Catholic church.
Okay? So the words pre naia, now we're gonna go to Naia
and I have to say happy birthday to the Council
of naia, which is back in 3 25 80.
Did you know it's the 1700th birthday of the Council of Na?
I bet you, I bet you don't knew that another, yeah, right?
Oh, are they? Yeah. I didn't know that.
Okay, so we are actually celebrating.
So the Council of NAIA was called by Constantine,
the upper of Rome.
And they weren't necessarily concerned with the Trinity
and discussing the doctrine of the Trinity.
But what they were concerned about was the doctrine
of Christ, who Christ is.
That was a big controversy in the church at that time.
And so it doesn't specifically talk about the Trinity,
but we can glean information about the
Trinity by what they said.
So we believe in one God, the Father Almighty
and is one Lord Jesus Christ, the son of God,
begotten from the Father, only the God
that is from the substance.
Okay? There's that word substance.
Again, this was composed in Greek.
So the Greek word there is cia. Okay? I've got up there.
Jesus Christ, the same substance of the Father,
God from God, light from light, true God from true God,
begotten, not made of one substance.
And now we tack on the prefix.
Cuomo meaning the same Cuomo, Lucia meaning same substance.
Okay? These were fighting words kind
of in the early church, okay?
There was a lot of divisiveness over this.
There was a lot of collaboration in the council
to really get to the bottom of who Jesus really is.
And what they came up with was that Jesus is of the same
substance as the Father.
So we're getting to that point of
how do you get three in one slowly
but through time, okay?
Through centuries of dialogue and study.
Are, are we gonna get there? Okay.
So that was the, but it's really
after the Ian time that we really start
to get into our modern definition of the Trinity.
And it's these guys, the cap, ocean fathers cap, Doha,
and I'll show you a map here in a couple slides.
Cap, nice was in Turkey, modern day Turkey
and just east of NAIA was a place called Cappadocia.
And these three church leaders in Cappadocia
really, um, paved the way
for our modern understanding of the Trinity.
Okay? So these cap ocean fathers,
and I'll quote basal of Caesarea here in 3 73 ad
we're therefore bound to confess the son to be
of one substance.
Okay? Here's that same language again of one substance.
The homo, who's a Greek figure with the father
as it's written notice he says as it's written,
but the father to exist in his own proper person.
And remember, Tulia used a Latin word persona,
and that's where we still,
after 1800 years now, use this word person okay?
To define what Jesus is in relation
to God, right?
But in Greek, there's this word, prepost
or hypostasis, okay, I've got up there.
I gotta say that's probably my favorite Greek word.
And for reasons of, it's just profound.
If you were to study this word,
and I've, I've tried my best to understand it.
Uh, it is really rich, it's very philosophical
and there's a lot of philosophy
that we are discussing here, okay?
Um, but what Basal had understood is
that the father
and the son exist thereof one substance,
but they exist in their own individual
hypostasis or hypostasis, okay?
That we're gonna, this, this little, this is deep mud
that we're dredging through, okay?
That this will, this will start to kind of,
will digest it thoroughly as we go.
Okay? He exists in his own proper person, the son and his
and the Holy Ghost and his,
as they themselves have clearly delivered the doctrine.
I'm glad Basal thinks it's clear. Do you think it's clear?
Mm-hmm. Okay. Yeah. Okay. I adjustment.
Yeah. And that's what basal was doing.
It's just screams at you. It does, it does.
What I think we need to do and what's missing
and why not everybody can say that, is we have
to tune our ears to that frequency.
And that is, that is, um, that comes with maturity,
that comes with prayer, that comes
with seeking the Holy Spirit
and asking him to illuminate these truths to us
that aren't necessarily spelled out in the black and white.
But basal at this time was saying it's clear,
it's clearly delivered.
And he thought of this as God is of one, what
substance and three, what
persons So hypostasis, okay,
he goes on because it's not all clear maybe
what these words are.
So he even actually defines these
words a couple years later.
He says the distinction between Lucia
and Hypostasis is the same as that
between the general and the particular.
And we come back to that.
In the case of the Godhead, we confess one essence
or substance, so as to not give a varying definition
of existence, but we confess a particular hypostasis in
order that our conception of the father, son,
and Holy Spirit may be without confusion
and Clear.
His goal was to make it clear
for the people, for us.
Okay? So now this distinction between Lucia
and Hypostasis, the general
and the particular, what does that mean, if you will
think of a human?
Okay. You can even just close your eyes, just think
of a human, okay?
Give you 20 seconds,
Okay? Now
open your eyes and here I am.
What you, what you were thinking of.
What were you thinking of?
What, what thoughts came to your mind when you did that?
Because this was a technique
that the early church actually used to think
between these two terms.
What, what did you think of when you thought of human?
Okay, but what she is a human, I'm sure,
but like what about,
I'm just talking about the nature of a human.
Like what is it that you think of? Physical body. A human.
Physical body. Okay, what else?
Spirit and soul. Spirit and soul.
There's an inside, inner, immaterial part to the human.
Anything else? Anything. Maybe a part of that,
Of the mind.
Reason. Reason.
So we have, uh, emotion maybe as well
part of that, part of the soul.
A volition a will we can desire. We can will things.
Conscience. Conscience, yeah. Okay.
So when I said here I am,
it may not have been exactly what you were thinking of
because you were thinking of the general, what is a human,
what things specifically are characterizing a human?
I am an example of one.
I promise, but
so are you or so are you.
Okay? So that's what he's talking about, the general
and the particular, I am a particular human.
Human is the general.
So now when we think about the
Godhead, what's he talking about?
This distinction is between God and the nature of God
and Father, son
and Holy Spirit are the particular, okay.
So do you see that difference?
Do you see the difference between the general, which is God
and the particular, which are the three persons of the God?
Is that clear? Okay. It's mud.
Thank you, David. So now to kind
of summarize this teaching is usia refers to what God is one
of, and hypostasis
or a person refers to what God is three of.
Okay? That's a, that's I think a good way to understand
between this one
and three, which we're getting back to your point earlier,
uh, of what we clearly understand,
but most of the rest of the world does not.
Okay? And then our friend Augustine, uh,
after that 400, he sums it up with this tongue twister here.
The Father and the Son and the Holy Spirit intimate a divine
unity of one and the same substance.
He was a Latin speaker in an indivisible equality, and
therefore that they are not three gods, but one God,
although the father have begotten the son.
And so he who is the father is not the son,
and the son is begotten by the Father.
And so he who is the son is not the father.
And the Holy Spirit is neither the father nor the son,
but only the spirit of the Father
and of the son himself, also co people with the father
and the son partake to the unity of the Trinity.
And now it's crystal clear, right?
He has a way, he has a way of speaking to
where he's summarizing all of this doctrine
that we've built up now over 200 years into one
digestible paragraph.
Okay? So now let's look at this on map
and let's go back to ion's right here in cartridge.
Okay, here two 13, he's writing about the Trinity.
We didn't discuss origin,
but he's over here in the Nile Delta in Alexandria,
in Northern Egypt, about that same time.
But he's also, he also came up with something very similar
to Ian regarding the Trinity.
Here is the council Ofia in 3 25,
the cap Ocean fathers 3 75,
and then finishing up with Augustine and 400.
What do you notice about this map pattern?
It's all over the place, isn't it?
They didn't have smartphones, they didn't have, uh, texts.
Origin was not texting tulia.
Hey, uh, buddy, what are you thinking about the Trinity?
Yeah, it was hard to get around
and you had to have something physical as far
as a correspondence to be able to communicate.
So think about how difficult it would be
to have consistent doctrine in this early church with
that basically is your playground.
You have base that I, I mean that's,
that's very similar to the size of us.
So think about it.
This is out here happening in Arizona, up here in New York.
They're discussing this.
It just helps us appreciate how this may have taken a couple
of centuries even really to get hammered out.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay, how are we doing with the typo?
We see where we're going. Are we in the middle
of the Grand Canyon kind of wobbling and shaking right now?
Are we looking down? Are we good on the definition?
Is there anything we want to go
over again with the definition? Is anything not
Clear?
Remember we're building something over two centuries
to get to where we want to go.
Okay? Does anybody happen?
Maybe this is for related hypo and stasis.
Is that a compound word that means something independent?
I don't know. And I agree to know. I'm glad asked it.
I I really want to talk an hour on this, but,
but I'm not, I can't, yes, it's compound word hubo
or hypo means under
and stasis means stand.
So if you think of our word understanding,
what does understanding mean in its etymology?
What does understand mean? It's, it's a weird word.
We kind of know how we use it, but what does it mean?
It means to stand under
and grasp something that's above you, that means to hold up
and understand what is
Being discussed right now.
So when you apply it to this in a hypostasis, you know,
what does that have to do with?
Um, God,
it actually does mean something philosophically that
Jesus as a hypostasis of God
is the reality in our view of what God is.
So, and Jesus even says it himself.
He who has seen me has seen a father.
So he is the visible image of the invisible God.
Paul says that too.
So that's exactly what that word hypostasis means.
It means a manifested reality
and understanding of what God is.
So when people saw Jesus,
if he walked in the room right now, we could say
there's everything God is right there.
That would be, he would be our manifested reality of
who God is when he walks in his door.
So it's a very rich philosophical term that we can go
with a lot more, but that's really the root of
what the word means as we break it down.
Yeah, that's a great question.
Anything else before we go on to talk about the essentials?
We're back to ham's definition now.
So we, I think we got past the deepest part of the canyon,
if you're still hanging in there. Yeah,
I, uh, that is a rich word and it's, it's deep
and it just makes me think of belief
to eliminate the Son who is the hypo
stasis of God, of God, our understanding
of God. And they have,
And they have done Of that.
And that's just
If, if without Jesus it says
He is the image, the visible image of the invisible God.
You take Jesus out of the picture.
You just had an invisible God. Yeah.
What do you do with that? You do with that
what humanity did until Jesus came
and revealed who God is.
This is why it is critical that God has a son.
And you can't go post enough signs
to say Jesus is not the son of God.
Because without that, what we have
anything to stand under, right?
So let's go to the, the, the, the definition of wing Bruno,
I'm gonna twist it 'cause I think you might have
gotten a little bit backwards.
Not, not that it's bad, but I'm gonna start with the end
of his definition of work forward.
There's one God, this is essential today.
This is essential number one, that there is one God.
So what does the scripture say?
Well, Isaiah 43 10 says Before me, no God was formed,
nor shall there be any after me.
I am Yahweh. There is no other God besides me.
There is no other God.
And if you want other passages, there's a few. Yeah.
Um, right.
I I don't think we need to harp on this too much of
what the scripture says about there's only one God,
but God himself is one
a slightly different twist on the same thing.
The Shama hero, Israel, Yahweh, our God, Yahweh is one
you shall love Yahweh, your God with all your heart
and with all your soul and with all your might.
So there's one God and he himself is one.
So we're getting a lot of ones here.
Doesn't mean that God is one. I know what it means.
That there's only one God that's monotheism.
What does it mean when it says God is one though
Unified?
Unified there has to there.
So unified means that there's something to unify, right?
Yes. So you go back to the scriptures again,
even the Old Testament
and I, I don't know if it's screaming,
but it's hinting it, it's hinting.
It's, it's, it's, it's disgusting it, right?
It's not hiding it.
Some gonna say maybe it is,
but it's there for the ones who as adhere
to here what's being said.
And Jesus himself affirms this in Mark.
So now we have our graphic, which is the other handout here,
and there's a lot on that graphic
and that's really something for you guys just to take
with you and digest it at your leisure.
But we're gonna actually build
that graphic here on the screen.
So I'm glad you're all sitting. Here's how we start.
There is one God,
and that's gonna be the blue circle in the middle, okay?
Now we're gonna go on to the central number two, uh,
before we do the five Solas, if you've heard
that of reformed theology, which is fairly recently,
church history speak.
Um, number five is this concept of so Deo Gloria,
which means to the glory of God alone.
So not only is he one God, he says, I am Yahweh
and that is my name and my glory.
I gift it no other, okay?
Amen on that. We're we're good on that.
The problem is, um, Jesus says this,
and now Father glorify me in your own presence
with the glory that I had with you before the world existed.
See any, uh, problems with that verse? The only problem
Is if you saw it as, uh, God as more than one God.
Uh, if you look at it from the verse, you look at it as
two persons and one God,
then it under then it's understanding.
Yeah. But do you see how the religious leaders
of the day wanted to throw stones at him
on face value is so humble.
It's completely glassless.
If you look at this at face value, yes, I know
where you're going and you're correct, but at face value
and at this part in our definition
and our, our dredging through bud to understand the trinity,
that seems to blatantly contradict that.
But we know it doesn't. So hang in there.
The remedy, the cure for this is essential number two.
And that is that God is three persons.
We see that in the scripture.
We can go back and we can look at how, uh,
hold back the beginning creation.
We brought up Genesis, right?
Genesis 1 26 says, then God said,
let us make man in our image, choose the us.
We have a couple of options.
None of 'em are good except the one we all know and love.
And that's Trinity. The other ones would be multiple guys,
angels hanging out with God.
Uh, but they don't create things, right?
Unless you understand verse one and two and two,
One and two. Verse one,
two, yeah, well, yeah, it's building up, right?
This is not just, I pulled that
of context, but without that.
But now let's go through the Trinity.
Have we not all one father and is not one God created us.
Malachi says the Father creates, right?
Paul says Jesus Christ, through whom we exist,
Paul says that Jesus creates,
Joe says, the Spirit of God made me.
So we have the Trinity as we peruse all of scripture, right?
And, and we talked about it.
The verse isn't there, the one verse,
the the gotcha verse isn't there,
but we don't read just one verse.
We read the whole book.
And the whole book, I agree screams Trinity.
So we can see that creation, we see salvation.
How much more will the blood of Christ to,
through the eternal spirit offered himself without blemish
to God, purify our conscience from the dead, from dead words
to serve the live in God.
Okay? We see him at work,
the tri God at work in the Trinity, and very similar here.
And Peter, I think we got our notes.
One God, three in authority go therefore
and make disciples of all nations,
baptizing them in the name of which means what?
In the authority of the Father of the Son
and the Holy Spirit, And was declared
to be the son of God in power according to the spirit
of holiness by his resurrection from the dead,
Jesus Christ, our Lord.
So the very event of the resurrection,
we all agree it's a very powerful event.
But there were three at work in the resurrection.
Jesus was just, it was the physical body that got raised,
but it was the Holy Spirit through God the Father.
And it was a, it was a team effort.
It was not just God, it was God,
but three in one God doing the resurrection, right?
You see that expanding.
Now our graphic with a central number two,
and we've got these three persons out here.
It's funny, I had, I had lunch with Joe Morrow
and I, we talked about this
and I told him, I, I made a graphic for this.
He's like, did you make it a triangle?
Like, yeah, spoil, spoiler. Alert. Alert.
Um, but with Augustine's help, we can actually start
to understand how these three are
distinct, right?
And his definition, he says the father is not the son.
Son is not the father. The spirit is
neither the father nor the son.
Okay? So this is where we're at now with essential one
and essential number two.
What we've gotta do now is go to
that essential number three, which is each of these persons
is themselves distinctly fully
God, Okay?
The Father is God.
We've seen Malachi,
and I don't think we're gonna camp out here too long
because I would say that this is probably the easiest part
of the lesson is, and you could go outside of our faith
and people would understand that the Father is God,
but the Son is also God.
And I won't read all this,
but you know, John one, one in the beginning was the word,
the word was with God.
And the word was God. You skipped down to verse 14.
And the word became flesh, okay?
That's clearly, clearly talking about Jesus
and his deity.
He even claims that I'm the Father are one.
Remember God, Yahweh is one.
Jesus says the same thing, I'm the Father are one.
So he's even getting himself into this oneness
Of God.
Paul tells Titus that Jesus is God.
John says that he's the true God of eternal life.
And we could put much more up there,
but we haven't gotten to Christology yet in this series.
We will next semester,
but, uh, we gotta least touch on this.
And here's the fundamentals, okay?
And this is Hebrews is a very, very deep book.
And the first four verses
of Hebrews are probably the deepest part
of the deep book of Hebrews.
And in verse three, it says, he being Jesus,
he is the radiance of the glory
of God in the exact imprint of his nature.
That Greek word is hypostasis.
Remember what that means? Jesus is the
exact representation of the reality
of God are, like I said, when he walks through the door,
when we see him, we see exactly everything
God is in him.
And it, it, ESV says nature.
I, I have a slight philosophical issue with that,
which I'm not gonna uh, pound the table on,
but the new King James probably gets it right, I think
or maybe a little bit more clear that says, uh,
they actually use the word person there for hypostasis.
'cause hypostasis, remember
that is what God is the three of.
So persons would be, I think philosophically the better
term to actually use there.
Um, Paul says, he breaks it down a little simpler here.
He says, he's the image jumping
and whoever has seen me has seen the Father.
Okay? We kind of talked about that already.
And the Holy Spirit is God,
but member Acts five, Peter said, Ananias,
why has Satan filled your heart to lie to the Holy Spirit?
You have not lied to man,
but to you God, that he's clearly
equating the Holy Spirit with God in that single sentence.
These things, God has revealed us through the Spirit.
Paul says in 20 years, for the spirit searches everything,
even the depths of God for
who knows the person's thoughts except the spirit of
that person which is in him.
So also no thoughts of God except the spirit of God.
That's a very unique relationship between the Spirit
and God, meaning that they are the same just as my spirit
and me understand each other.
So the Spirit and God are one and the same.
Okay, back to the graphic, what do we do
with this essential number three?
Well, there's paths of each of them to
The God, okay, this isn't perfect, this is as good
as I could put together on PowerPoint.
Um, I'm sure there's a better one,
but this will, this will suffice I think right now.
So this is kind of the basics of the graphic
that you've got, which I filled in a bunch of verses
and everything else that you can kind
of go reference, don't believe me.
Go look at these verses up, read 'em for yourselves,
meditate on those and really truly seek what the meaning
of trinity is.
So that or in your understanding. So hey Dan, yeah.
Review number two guys through person three blanks.
The second one, one.
So
The mixed up on second And third.
I, I did, I I switched the slides after I made the thing.
Sorry. Um, yeah, it's creation.
And then the next one on your handout would be authority.
And then the next one is salvation, I believe. Sorry.
Good catch. Alright, so now
that we've got the essentials down, understand
what the definition is of the, of the trinity, we ought
to now understand what happens when one
of those essentials gets tweaked a little bit.
Okay? This is, this is the tightrope again and we the wall
and we start to sway from one side to the next.
Let's start with errors in this first
that there is one God, okay?
The opposite of monotheism would be polytheism, right?
We talked about that. There's a definition of it up there.
The belief in of for worship of more than one God
about some examples, Hinduism, Buddhism,
Mormonism, Jehovah's Witnesses,
and nearly every ancient religion, uh,
they were notorious for finding multiple things
to worship in their world.
Mormons, Jehovah's Witnesses, um, at the very root
of it are, are polytheistic
and their belief system, um, Jesus is a God.
That means that other ones to including the Father.
So multiple gods. That's a fairly easy one though.
What about these other ones? So if there's errors in
essential number two, then God is three persons.
What happens here? Well, this, what we find is
that people merge persons of the Trinity, they combine them
or they omit one or more persons of the trinity.
So if there's not three persons anymore,
what are some examples?
Modalism, if you've heard of that, that God offers, uh, uh,
he, uh, he operates and, and,
and modes like the Father does this, the son does
that the Holy Spirit does that.
Whatever the need is. That was a very early document.
The church, Islam
and Judaism, we might classify them
as other religions or whatever,
but at the root of it, they are, uh, the error is that
they did not believe in free persons of God.
And right here in our town of Evan,
the Philadelphia church is God according to their website,
they deny the person of dis
or the the Holy Spirit that puts them in this.
So these are just some examples.
Um, yeah, the father is the son is the spirit.
Okay, so we go back to the graphic.
All those words that say is not you would just take the
knots off and say is,
and that's what this era would look like in the early
church, especially when we talk about modalism,
what modalism is. Yeah,
Modalism is
Another way of saying it, is that God might show up today
as, or might be referred to today, reveal as father,
but in another situation in a few more minutes,
might be able to spirit like one at a time.
Yeah, kind of a one at a time.
As, as as more of a functional thing.
So when, when God wants to do this, he does it as the son.
When God wants to do this, he does it as the Holy Spirit
as modes.
There's different modes of operation within the God.
For example one.
Dan, would it be a stretch to say that a cessationist church
Regard spiritual gifts Here no longer?
I wouldn't, I wouldn't go that far.
I think you can still believe
that there the Holy Spirit is deity and part of the godhead
and not believe he supplies certain gifts anymore.
That wouldn't necessarily remove any godness?
I wouldn't think so just off the top
of my head I probably wouldn't do it that far.
Was there another
I got a question. Yeah,
I Had been thinking about this I guess after the last,
and I was thinking that as a musical chord
notes, so played the,
like kids play.
Do you think of that analogy?
I I I you'll you'll notice I didn't put any analogies in
this class because I all bad.
I I I appreciate that.
I appreciate the SUN analogy.
I appreciate the ones that says I am multiple things.
I'm a dad and a son at the same time,
but I'm not, I operate in different modes.
I can't, I can't do it all at the same time like God does.
And three like a CNE
and a G, yeah, it's beautiful together
and they're individual, but you can play them individually
and you don't have to have 'em
as a chord and even as a chord.
They're three distinctly separate notes
and they don't really have a functional tie
to the cord necessarily.
So I stopped short
of analogies.
You're saying good thinking though. I love it.
I love the, but it's very hard
to find something like the trinity in our natural
world and in our experience.
Um, and we have to really be honest
that there isn't anything like it.
This doctrine is not something we can duplicate
in our understanding in our minds.
It just is not, we have to take these concepts.
We have to, we have to research 'em, we have
to build 'em up, we have to understand them, we have
to believe them And we kind
of will hit a wall at some point.
I don't believe that that wall is um, reach just
yet because I do believe
that we're still supposed to see this.
We're still supposed to study this.
We're still still supposed to meditate on who God is,
Can't fully know him, but we can know him
And but we can know him
and we can know him better tomorrow than we do today.
And we can knowing better the day
after that than we did tomorrow.
And so there's still grounds for searching
and seeking in our faith to grow in our faith.
So that wall, we may never hit the wall until
it's our last
breath, but there is a wall.
We are not God and we will not be God
and we will not fully understand this.
Maybe, probably ever, maybe,
but especially not in this lifetime.
So let's go on to errors in this third essential here.
That each person is fully God.
Do you see the difference between essential two and three?
Is that true that God is three
persons, is number two?
Number three is each of those persons is fully gone.
Okay? Is that distinction clear?
Do you, okay, so let's,
what happens if we get something wrong here?
This error diminishes or removes one
or more attributes of God from one
of the persons of the Trinity.
Okay? Lemme go through that again.
This error diminishes or removes one
or more attributes of God from a person of the trinity.
The example is Arianism, okay?
A very popular heresy in the early church did not believe
that Jesus was full of God.
Subordinationism, that is
a hierarchy in nature, not in function.
So that means that one is lesser in nature
than the other, okay?
And that we can't, we can't do that adoption isn't
that Jesus was just an adopted son, okay?
His baptism, he became God's
son Again.
You've got five minutes and David's gonna come up here.
What I'm going to do is now bring this home.
This was a lot of Dr through mud.
This was a lot of academia.
This is a lot of, um, funny Greek words.
This is a lot of stuff that you know, we have in our heads.
Now what do we do with it once it's in our heads?
I'm a firm believer that you,
God put this stuff in your heads,
but what do we do with it now?
How does it affect our live lives?
So let's go back to our salvation and let's see how God
and his triunity works in our salvation.
Paul says in conclusions in him, you also,
when you heard the word truth, the gospel of your salvation
and believed in him, Jesus were sealed
with the promised Holy Spirit who is the guarantee
of our inheritance until we acquire possession of it
to the praise of His glory.
See how they work together?
We all know the gospel where it says believe in
him, believe in Jesus.
What happens to the Holy Spirit then enters our
life at that moment.
Okay, we're in. Dwell with the Holy Spirit
Is a beautiful reality of the three in one,
working in unity.
Triunity working in unity, right?
Jesus says, when the spirit of truth comes,
he will guide you into all the truth.
For he will not speak on his own authority.
Notice he calls him, he is not a dick,
always fears a he. Why is he a he
A person? 'cause
he's a person, he's God.
Same pronouns can do what the Father is the Son.
But whenever he hears, he will speak interesting
and he will declare you the things
that have become He will glorify me.
Remember, Jesus was asking for the Father to glorify him
and now he's saying that the Spirit will also glorify him.
This glory that God said he would give
to no other is shared.
A hundred percent, a hundred percent,
a hundred percent within the trinity.
Each gets glory in its fullest.
But he will take what is mind.
Jesus says, and declare it to you.
All of the Father has is mind.
Therefore I said that He will take what is mind
and declare to you everything the Father has as mind
and the Holy Spirit will tell you this is a beautiful image
of how the Trinity works in this scenario.
Jesus is talking about, this is our daily life.
This is whenever we need help. Whenever we need help.
How often we need help. I need lot, a lot.
It's the triune God supplying this help to us.
He's our equipper. Now there are varieties of gifts, okay?
These are spiritual gifts, but the same spirit
and there are varieties of service, but the same board.
There's varieties of activities,
but there's the same God who empowers them all in everyone.
It is God dispensing to all believers,
these gifts, the same spirit, the same board,
the same God equipment.
And last one, he's our unity.
This is
Guys, This is amazing and God, God is one.
There is unity in God, but he's trying you.
So there's trinity in the unity.
But this trinity now becomes the basis for us
as individual persons
to have unity with each other.
This is what the verse says.
There is one body and one spirit just as you are called
to the one hope that belongs to you, to your call.
One Lord, one faith, one baptism, one God,
and Father of all who is over all and through all.
And in all the triune God is
the sole basis for why we as individual people,
I'm not blood related to any of you,
but you're all brothers and sisters.
That just blows me away as an only child.
And that's very special to me.
I now have lots of brothers and sisters and I love 'em all.
And it's because of the tri of God equipping us
and causing us to be kindred spirits with each other.
Right? So the Trinity is not just important
academically, it's, it is our life.
This document is our life.
It's our, it's our function within the church.
It's our reason for living.
It's our, it's the unification of all of us as Christians.
Okay? And with that, I can stick around afterwards
for questions, but we have a, we have a guest teacher here.
Give it up Dave. Everybody
I like. Thank you.
Okay, so everybody hold your hands up,
stand up, get some blood flow.
You're gonna need it all. Here we go.
Okay, go ahead and sit back down.
This is the book that we had one,
the books we had recommended
for the court delighting in the Trinity.
It is awesome. Please read it.
Delighting Trinity written by Michael Reeds.
He is the president of the seminary in Wales back, uh,
Wells pastor that was recently here,
uh, came and everything.
He's attending his seminary.
So, okay,
so we've been talking about the Trinity and who God is.
So a lot of times we look at God, we may think of God
as a creator and river.
We talked a little bit about that a couple weeks ago.
But in reality, God is loved
because he exists as a trinity.
So how do we know God is loved?
How do we know?
Thought? Say something.
Okay, good. Do you have an example
of it off the top of your head
That Okay, I'll let my brother, uh, two.
Go ahead. Four.
She said it. Four. I cheated. What'd you say first John.
Four. Okay.
Or go ahead Paul.
Way I the truth and the life.
No one comes to father except through me. Okay.
That's John. 14, six John 14. Six. Okay.
Uh, piano man. What's another one?
John 1724.
Father I retired that they also,
and you have given me, may be with me where I am
to see my glory that you have given me.
'cause you left me before the foundation of the world.
We know God is love 'cause he's a father
and Jesus is his son.
He loves the son. That life-giving love of the Son.
The triune God includes the Father, the Son,
and the Holy Spirit.
The Father is so-called because he is a life-giving father
and father's children.
God has always existed as a father throughout eternity
is naturally outgoing and life giving.
And one John,
or yeah, first John four, it says, let us love one another.
For love comes from God.
Everyone who loves has been born of God and knows God.
Whoever does not love God,
but whoever does not love does not know God
because God is love.
Okay, so you ready?
But how does genuine love
from God differ from the love that a wicked man,
such as as he shows love to his son?
How is that different?
It's steadfast, unconditional.
Unconditional. See, would he not, would
that wicked man not have unconditional towards his own son?
That own Person. His own person? Okay.
Anyone else?
Imagine a love that's, that's gonna meet your every need
based on how much and what exactly you need it to be.
It's a love that with Jesus is full of grace
and truth we talked about maybe two weeks ago.
It's, it's perfect love.
We, we might be able to have unconditional love as far
as we're able to define it and act on uncondition.
But I would, I would argue
that his is perfectly unconditional.
Okay, good. And his is perfectly full
of grace when we need grace
and perfectly full of truth when we need truth.
And that love is really hard to replicate in our,
in ourselves, right?
And, and, and I don't know that we can,
Right?
You had, so, uh, just while we were still centered back
for us that perfect.
Good. Alright, so let's skip on here
and know that in four,
since the Christian God is striking the tri, the Trinity
is at the heart of all Christian faith shaping
and strengthening every other truth.
It supports all Christian thinking.
So now we get to get personal here we'll go.
Do you consider the relationship within the triune God,
when you form your thoughts, how you respond
to somebody else, you actually think that through.
That's how the, the relationship of God the father
and loving and the Son
and that reflection of his love back to the Father.
You think about that the way when you respond to somebody,
when they then, when they've done something
or said something to you, you think about that love
that you've received.
Anybody have any examples?
I know that's a tough one, but I wanted to go there just
to help us because a Aaron always, in some of his classes,
he was talking about how we gotta think about
how God would think and take it
and take all of our thoughts, Kathy, in the mind to
what God would be thinking right before him.
Naturally our response,
and This applies them here,
love even when it's hard, how can, how can you
intentionally show love to someone difficult today?
And what specific steps can you take to see them
through God's eyes?
You realize they're, they're broken.
You know, God loves me a broken person.
God also gonna love that as person.
We need to be a witness to, to show them that love
God, you.
And if they're not a
Christian, how are they gonna know you?
That love right? Says they'll know I love him.
Alright, let the
Trinity shape your identity.
How can you remind yourself each day that your
identity is rooted in God's life
and your relationship with the Father, the Son,
and the Holy Spirit?
How can you remind yourself each day that your identity,
who you are as a Christian
who may born again, you have the Holy Spirit,
and how do you remind yourself on that?
And now God's love and your relationship with him,
I say ways and just our existence that all those
that of God life through
with spirit that speaks up in the Creation act.
So just the fact that we wake up, we take a breath in,
there's life and a breath.
Mind of the Spirit reminded our position
of being called sons
and daughters adopted, that just our existence within
his family and our relationship remains based on our
identity as being sons
and daughters, which will inherit by Jesus' son,
which give us relationship to the Father
that we be His presence.
Speak to the Father, spoken.
Um, so just outta existing.
Alright, thank you. That's all I got.
So, so
why don't we stand
The
Pray for us.
Lord, I don't believe we touched on a 10th
of this doctrine tonight, that
that is the reality of you are.
But Lord, we did the best that we can.
And we feel you in this, this lest the Father
and I pray that the words tonight would be,
Would, uh, would go with everybody as they leave this place.
Father. And this, these words would
rest on our souls tonight, even as we go in our cars
to go home, as we lay down in bed
and our thoughts just come rushing in.
Father, I I pray that
we wouldn't drown out these thoughts tonight.
That these thoughts would occupy us.
That we fall asleep to these thoughts tonight.
And we wake up to these thoughts tomorrow morning
and go about our day, go back to work, think about it.
And the next day, father
and I I know there, I know that there's a, a wall
between man and God.
But Father, help us always to be driving towards that wall.
Just equip us, power us as you know, that you've
provided the, the, the way for us to be able to come to you
closer and closer each day.
And I pray that for everybody here,
where we would just increase our faith every day
as you allow Father, equip us, meet us where we're at,
pick us up, carry us to the next stage,
and just trust you to do that work.
Be with everybody's relief here.
Keep us safe. Watch over us.
Protect Jesus.
Please make sure you sign the wrong
I a question.
Okay. Taking for credit, credit, we're supposed
to get our midterm today.
I Is that gonna be? Yeah.
Well, his mom passed away, so it's gonna be a couple days.
So you still have right? Okay.
Huh? You small marks. Hey,
where's, uh, mark, Ms.
Rudy,
bus t
Everything good?
All behind. Behind. Little behind.
Okay. You can catch up? Yep. All right.